les agents de police ont été appelés sur
les lieux lundi aux alentours de 3h30 du
matin
aucun mobile ou explication possible
[Musique]
et il ya une fête ce soir ça va être
cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la police de la ville en quelle sera
multiple aux minimes en tous points
similaires dont meurtre tristement
célèbre perpétrés par l'adil tu avais
raison c'est la même maison nerveux se
dit dit michael tu es une fille sage toi
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas assez poussé
nos recherches ceci est la destinée et
toi aussi tu en fais partie
j'ai envie de voir comment on fait
il a besoin de toi
comme j'ai besoin de toi
même antoine r
les gars
[Musique]
t'as aucune raison d'être triste